in the world of One Piece there's a rare
phenomenon of devil fruit Awakening that
only a handful of characters have
managed to achieve this mysterious
process makes devil fruit users
infinitely more powerful and grants them
many impressive new abilities so today
we'll be explaining all 10 devil fruit
users who manage to awaken their powers
starting with the strongest member in
cp9's history Rob Lucci at some point in
his life Luchi ate the Neko Neko no me
model leopard and despite it obviously
granting him the ability to turn into a
human leopard this fruit also
dramatically increased his physical
strength as shown when he easily threw
Luffy and Zorro through a building
across the whole city upon Awakening
this fruit luchi's hybrid form undergoes
a physical transformation where its size
increases his body becomes more slim and
a dark flame forms a main down his back
and arms Luchi mostly uses this fruit to
make his rokushiki techniques like
shigon and rankyaku more powerful
utilizing claws on his fingers and the
strength in his legs he also learned to
use SEMA kikan which allows him to
freely manipulate his body parts Luchi
mostly uses this to shame can compresses
muscles transforming him into a smaller
more human form in which he's much
faster than usual although Luchi had
incredible growth throughout the series
and became much stronger he ultimately
proved to be no match for Luffy in his
gear fifth form and thereafter deserves
to be placed in a tier Charlotte
karakuri karakuri is the strongest Suite
commander of the big mom Pirates and the
governor of the komogi island his devil
fruit is called Mochi mochinomi and it's
a special paramecia devil fruit that
allows him to create control and
transform into Mochi karakuri uses this
ability in many unique ways like
transforming his leg into Mochi and
using it as a weapon creating thick
Mochi and using it to entrap his
opponents and even enlarging his limbs
to a gigantic size and stretching them
to increase his attack range heck I
wouldn't be surprised if this guy could
even make a subscribe button out of
Mochi and then make people click it
please guys just subscribe so I can stop
making these stupid subscribe jokes
every video thanks anyway on the one
hand Kara Goody's fruit is pretty
similar to Luffy's fruit as it allows
katakuri to extend his limbs but one
major difference is that due to mochi
mochi no me being a special paramecia
fruit can also fully transform his body
into Mochi similar to lobium users once
katakuri mastered and awakened this
fruit it even enabled him to transform
nearby material into Mochi greatly
enhancing the range of his attacks and
allowing him to manipulate the
environment to his Advantage even though
katakuri eventually lost his 21 episode
long fight against Luffy it's obvious
that he's an incredibly strong fighter
and therefore deserves to be placed in a
tier there are still eight more
extremely powerful characters left to
cover and the next one is the Puppet
Master Don Quixote do Flamingo no
flamingo is a former warlord of the sea
whoa Ito Ido no me a paramecia type
devil fruit that allows him to create
and manipulate strings though Flamingo
usually uses this fruit by bending his
fingers to move strings as he pleases
and manipulates people like puppets he
can also use these strings to cut his
targets and destroy their weapons Show
when he managed to cleanly sever little
Lord Jr's leg in One Swift motion and
even decapitate crocodile his defensive
capabilities are also no joke as he
could cross his strings to form a net
slicing in half an asteroid in order to
protect himself due to him mastering the
power of this fruit he managed to awaken
it which made him an even bigger monster
his awakened fruit allows him to
transform the ground in buildings around
him into Strings and use them for his
attacks when utilizing this new power
doflamingo tends to stay on the ground
shaping his strings into sharp tentacles
and unleashing them down on Targets in
addition these new awakened strings can
also be infused with Armament hockey
grabbing doflamingo even more offensive
power it's needless to say that
doflamingo was one of the strongest
Warlords in the series and therefore B
tier should be a Fitting Place for him
Awakening and so in devil fruit can be a
bit different than paramecia Awakening
as it comes with the risk of the
animal's nature consuming the user this
can cause them to lose their
personalities and become simple mind
abuse which is exactly what happened to
the next characters on the list the
awakened zoens of impell down these
characters are Mino zebra the user that
ain't zebra fruit Nino rhinoceros the
user that ate Rhino fruit minotares the
user who ate Holstein cow fruit and Mino
koala the user that ate koala fruit
before awakened Jailer beasts are the
most feared creatures within impel down
due to their great strength bloodlust
and ruthlessness due to them being being
awakened Zone users they're also
incredibly durable and recover from
injuries really fast however even with
these abilities they can still be
relatively easily defeated by strong
Fighters such as Luffy jinbei and
crocodile it's also important to mention
that although they're the strongest
guards there's some stronger people
working in prison such as Magellan
Hannibal and maybe even Saudi these Zone
users are obviously the weakest
characters on the list so far and
deserve to be placed in D tier caucus
Kaku is currently a member of cp0 the
strongest intelligence organization
working directly under the world Nobles
we were first introduced to Kaku during
the water 7 Arc and later during any
sloppy we witnessed him acquiring the
power of ushiushi no me model giraffe
this Zone type devil fruit allowed Kaku
to transform into either hybrid or full
giraffe form at will although giraffe is
a mostly harmless animal Kaku quickly
demonstrated how effective and deadly
this fruit can be in the right hands
especially when combined with his
rokushiki skills in the four sword style
allowing him to overpower Zoro in battle
and almost defeat him upon Awakening his
fruit Kaku could assume a new much more
powerful hybrid form which greatly
enhanced his physical strength speed as
well as his recovery rate in this form
his already long giraffe neck becomes
even longer in serpent-like enabling him
to perform powerful cutting movements
with it same as Luchi Kaku didn't lose
his personality while Awakening The Zone
fruit which made him infinitely stronger
than impel down jailers who completely
lost their identity due to the fruit's
power as noted by Zara the only real
weakness of this devil fruit is having a
long and very exposed neck that can be
easily exploited however despite this
Kaku proved himself to be a pretty tough
opponent for straw hats and I think BTR
would be a perfect place for him with
this we're exactly halfway through the
video which means that there's still 5
more characters who fully managed to
awaken their devil fruit Powers so let's
continue with the one you may not know
about Guild Tesoro DeSoto was the owner
of the largest entertainment City ship
in the world and served as the main
antagonist of the one-piece film gold
the fruit he ate is called gorogoro Nomi
and it allows him to manipulate gold at
will for example he can quickly change
the state of gold to either liquid or
solid and can shape it in any way he
desires you can even encase living
beings in Gold turning them into golden
statues in terms of defensive abilities
Tesoro can cover his own body with gold
creating a strong golden armor that's
hard enough to withstand extremely
powerful in attacks including hits from
gear 4 Luffy and cuts from zoro's three
sword style techniques since consuming
this devil fruit Tesoro has been able to
awaken his powers gaining even further
influence over gold this enabled him to
use all of the gold on the ship as an
observation system allowing him to
detect break-ins or attacks on the city
with this he also gained the ability to
unleash explosive beams of metallic
energy that were powerful enough to
destroy the entire Marine warship
although this fruit is extremely
powerful it has some weaknesses namely
DeSoto can't create any new gold he can
only use the gold present in his
surroundings which means that this route
is pretty much useless if there's no
gold lying around I mean no wonder this
guy lived on a huge floating Casino
eustiskin Captain used his kid is a
notorious pirate from South blue as well
as one of the strongest members of the
worst generation kid ate the jiki Chiki
no me a paramecia type devil fruit which
allows him to create magnetic force and
use them to control metal kid makes
excellent use of his devil fruit during
combat for example he can repel metallic
objects away from himself such as
cannonballs or attract objects within
his vicinity and create mechanical
Contraptions this ability also makes him
extremely powerful against fighters who
use metal weapons as he can easily
disarm them using his devil fruit and
use their weapons as building materials
however kids favorite way to use his
fruits power is to form gigantic
metallic arms connected to his actual
ones and use them in close range combat
after fully mastering and Awakening his
devil fruit kid unlocked a new ability
to manifest magnetic properties onto his
Targets this basically means that if kid
targets someone with a significant
amount of metal surrounding them they'll
quickly be crushed with Force being
strong enough to even rip large
structures towards them he can also
stick opponents to a piece of the
environment like a magnet rendering them
immobilized and vulnerable to all
attacks despite his newly awakened
abilities being incredibly strong kid is
not yet used to them and therefore only
uses them as the last resort during
tough battles with this in mind I don't
think I can place kid any higher than b
tier truffle guard D waterline same as
kid lies also a pirate captain and one
of the strongest members of the worst
generation as devil fruit is called obey
ope no me and it allows him to create a
force field in which he can freely
modify anyone or anything this fruit is
renowned for allowing the law to perform
miraculous surgeries and cure
untreatable diseases it's also known as
the ultimate devil fruit because of its
unique power to Grant another person
Eternal youth in exchange for the user's
own life for this reason the world
government is willing to pay 5 billion
bellies to anyone who can deliver this
route to them besides the fruit's
medical capabilities law is also very
skilled in using it during combat either
to redirect attacks coming at him or to
disarm his opponents furthermore the
obey obey no me makes law Well Suited at
fighting long-range battles since he can
practically control the entire fighting
area as long as his powers are active
having achieved The Awakening of this
fruit lobbycame capable of coding
objects with the spaced distorting
Essence allowing him to increase their
size or make them phase through targets
mom primarily utilizes these new powers
with his sword releasing powerful
internal shock waves on his victims
after piercing them although Law's devil
fruit is arguably among the strongest
ones on this list since he's still not
used to its full Powers I can't really
put him in s tier before we cover the
strongest awakened devil fruit user on
this list let's quickly go over one of
the former members of the Roger Pirates
Douglas Bullitt during his youth mullet
was a member of the Roger Pirates and
was later captured and imprisoned and
impelled down for over 20 years however
after Luffy and Blackbeard broke into
the prison he escaped with other inmates
while it ain't the goshagasha know me a
paramecia type devil fruit that allows
him to telekinetically disassemble and
reassemble objects into whatever he
pleases with the fruit's power bullet
could create large mechanical structures
including submarines and robot suits in
order to increase his fighting prowess
like other characters on this list he
also managed to awaken his fruit which
allowed him to manipulate objects from a
much greater range and even restructure
the landscape of entire Islands as he
saw fit bullet can also use this power
on himself along with Armament hockey in
order to enter a powered State similar
to how Luffy enters his gear 4 forms in
this state his body turned shining blue
with red eyes and his arms are expanded
and compressed to Grant him maximum
offensive power one major downside to
this fruit though is that it's entirely
dependent on the resources bullet has at
his disposal and he also must know
exactly what he's making and how it's
made meaning it's also limited by his
mechanical knowledge ultimately since
bullet isn't a Canon character I can't
place him any higher than C tier Monkey
D Luffy as we all know at the beginning
of the series Luffy ate the gomagomanomi
a paramecia type double fruit that
granted his body the properties of
rubber effectively turning him into a
rubber human however only recently in
the manga did we discover that louvi's
fruit is actually called hidohitonomi
Model Nika and that it's actually a
mythical Zone proof that allows Luffy to
turn into the sun god according to the
five Elders this fruit has not been
awakened for centuries before Luffy did
it and based on their reactions it's
clear that they're terrified of its
power the first time he awakened this
fruit Luffy's appearance changed
drastically with his hair enclosed
turning white his eyebrows resembling
Spirals and steam wrapping all around
him however this Awakening didn't only
change Luffy's appearance as he also got
many new combat abilities such as freely
manipulating the shape and size of his
body manipulating the environment around
him like it's made of rubber and even
stretching anything he touches with all
these new abilities Luffy was finally
able to bring down one of the four
Emperors of the sea kaido and if he
managed to do that the other characters
on this list should pose no real threat
to him therefore Luffy is the first
character that deserves to be in the S
tier click on this video where we
explained what would happen if some of
the strongest one-piece characters ate
devil fruits